hi i'm jacqueline grazer and i play
fraser wilson
hi my name is jordan christine simone
and i play caitlyn poitras
hi i'm francesca scorsese and i play
brittany hey what's up you guys my name
is spencer ii and i play danny poitras
and we are the cast that we are who we
are and we're here to play a little game
with buzzfeed
of who's who
who is most likely to survive a zombie
apocalypse
honestly me yeah i already have it all
mapped out i have like
when i was 11 i made like a pack of like
like a suitcase full of the things i
would need
i don't know where that where that thing
went but i was i was prepared
actually no either me or jordan i don't
know i think after playing caitlyn and
learning how to shoot a gun i could
survive a zombie apocalypse who's most
likely to show up late to set because
they were exploring the italian
countryside
i mean i was late to set like like once
right you were late during the photo
shoot
all right relax can we we gotta throw it
all out there cool
i feel like it would fear spence to be
quite honest i'm usually late for like
everything
i'll take that responsibility of being
late to set my attention like spending
is really really low
so i could be like right here sometimes
and i'll just be like over here like
zoned off
who's most likely to get caught sneaking
out of their house past curfew
you jack business
your mom would find you anywhere
anywhere in any way
who's the best at giving relationship
advice none of us
who's like the wisest of the four i mean
maybe spence
no dude i might turn to spence for some
relationship advice probably
i would turn to fran i friend i would
ask you some questions if i was like
help me young help me definitely not me
yeah that's a lot of pressure
who's most likely to give the silent
treatment when they're upset
jordan me or jordan but jordan jordan
does
wait a second hold on okay no actually i
would i do
okay who's most likely to pull a prank
on set yeah you
yeah yeah yeah i know this is really a
prank but i kept telling people that i
would like see something and i'd be like
dude i swear on my life
i swear to god i just saw an alligator i
swear to be like wait really
i swear on my life you also crew pasta
oh yeah i think i did that because i was
just
like i i was supposed to like walk onto
like the little thing where we were
sitting
and i stepped in the pasta with my foot
and i was like oh it's already ruined
now no one's gonna eat this i might as
well just like throw it on people
who's most likely to introduce you to a
band slash musician that you've never
heard of
jordan jordan yeah 100 jordan yeah
your music game is up to speed yeah and
you have like so much versatility with
what you like i think too oh my god guys
stop
who's the best at doing impressions of
their other cast members
should we test this out though i mean
probably me yeah yeah
jack do impressions of all three of us
oh my god this is so hard
okay i'm gonna go down the line right
now spence francesca jordan spends hey
great job man you did such a great job
like you're my favorite actor of all
time
okay francesca would be like oh my god
that's so cute
okay and jordan would be like i need to
go home now
i hate you who's most likely to nail a
scene on the first take
definitely not me how many spence is
like the most prepared always
surprisingly like drilling the script
every single night
yeah i'll take that i'll take that one
who's most likely to improvise their
lines
you improvise oh well yeah maybe me
give me your paw remember oh yeah give
me a little that was
that was from the last episode who's
most likely to get caught at craft
services
i'll take that i'll vote myself like i
was always eating the
set i swear the first time i hung out
with you
you ordered like three sandwiches and an
entire pizza and you ate the entire
thing i ate it
and my mom was there and she was looking
at you like your mom was actually
worried for my health i was concerned
you're gone dude
who's least like their on-screen
character i feel like we all kind of
like
stretched ourselves so much for the for
the for playing these characters
so i mean i don't know who's least like
they're on screen i think we're all
pretty
different from our characters who's the
least like if we were to choose one who
would it be
i want to say spence because spence is
like not an angry guy ever i've never
seen spence
actually oh actually yeah one time oh
i know what you're talking about two
jack paintball day
it's because i'm competitive and then
it's like what i want to do well it's
something i can't do well it
edit like i get frustrated and then like
sometimes just like keep the frustration
inside but i'm just like
it comes out like that
you